[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the pods
moving and storage studio it's the
ramsey show where debt is dumb cash is
king and the paid off home mortgage has
taken the place of the bmw as the status
symbol of choice we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing
relationships
thank you for joining us open phones at
triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five five two two five george
campbell ramsey personality host of the
podcast uh the fine print and of course
entre leadership and are we announcing
yet your new endeavor i think we are now
dave okay i mean you're already letting
the cat out of the bag well that cat he
was scrambling in the bag anyway but uh
on thursday george and rachel will
launch a new podcast called the smart
money happy hour yes we are so excited
about this more about smart money and
less about drinking but both are
involved we wanted to at least feel
inviting in a happy hour there's a level
of calm casualness we're not here to
yell at you this one we wanted this to
be kind of your friends hanging out
talking about money or at least the
friends you wish you had or not you
can't apply to be rachel's friend she
has enough does she yes but we can apply
to be your friend you know i could use
some friends today i don't have as many
as you'd think george i'm i'm i'm
shocked but it's fun we're just you know
we're two money experts who happen to be
friends talking about the stuff you wish
your friends were talking about and
money pop culture entertainment and
that's what this is we want people this
you could send this to a friend and go
hey you don't have to care about the
ramsay show we just want to talk about
things that matter to you and that one
of those things is money one of the
reasons we're launching that this week
on the ramsey network is we're
celebrating 30 years of the ramsey show
this week yeah crazy
and uh we're doing a whole bunch of fun
stuff including uh today's show we'll
have all the different ramsey
personalities on george called it speed
dating a little bit earlier so for a
couple segments each one of them will be
with me today who's going to get the
rose find out later
[Laughter]
well george's obviously see you so there
you go uh you're my favorite co-host
that's on right now man that 20 bucks
went a long way guys that's all it takes
but we had a good time this morning
celebrating with our whole team i mean
balloons videos telling stories did you
ever think back then you're like one day
i'll be celebrating a 30th anniversary
of this show no i didn't i i i have
thought ever since we've been on the air
we were going to get fired at any moment
and actually we have been fired a bunch
of times the good news is is that we
work for ourselves so uh when we get
fired it's just some local radio station
we had a guy in alabama call me up one
time to go ramsay i gotta take you off
the air and i'm like why man what did i
do now i mean what what you know those
are all we're always arguing the radio
stations back and forth we've got almost
700 of them so there's someone to argue
with all the time about something
and uh he said
you're gonna kill somebody and i said
i'm gonna kill somebody
i'm like how can i kill somebody i'm
telling people to get out of debt are
they going to die from getting out of
debt and he goes no your show's so
boring people listening to it are going
to fall asleep while they're driving and
run off the road and die oh my goodness
that's amazing he was serious as a heart
attack it was really pretty funny but uh
i started laughing i said well i got it
yeah i don't even have a comeback for
that dude so just cancel it it's all
good of course he's not the radio
business anymore a lot of things dave
but i wouldn't say boring is one of them
well yeah i mean just it depends on
where you're coming from you know so but
yeah it's uh
it's uh we have we told the team earth
this morning we have failed
a lot in 30 years we just didn't quit
it's really the only difference uh we
failed all the time i mean we the number
of radio stations i have been on
uh we're currently on 680 i guess it is
number two talk radio station show in
america today
uh marconi winter multiple radio hall of
fame all this other stuff all these
accolades nowadays but uh but boy
they're you know we have we have been on
i think in some cities we've been on
everybody that carried talk one time or
another i mean we've like been all the
way around the horn
like uh you know it's being in a small
town dating all the girls you know i
mean it's just like it's crazy so
but we've been
and sometimes we moved from the least
one all the way up to the best one and
sometimes we've moved from the best one
down to the least one in terms of signal
size or whatever but now it's moved so
far beyond radio i mean there's 17 other
places you can watch and listen and
amazing i mean youtube and podcasts
together are now bigger than talk radio
on our on our show anyway wow i mean
there's about 12 or 14 million of them
and there's a little under 10 million on
the radio show so it's somewhere around
20 something million total and uh it
used to be more used to be more than
half was talk radio but talk radio is
not uh front and center with everybody
like it used to be it's still very
strong though still very viable but
that's of course where this whole thing
started so yeah and it's gone through a
lot of iterations from it was originally
called the money game
um and uh then uh we changed it when it
was just me after that the guys that
started it with me one has passed away
and the other one went on to do other
things and i kept going and then we
changed it to the dave ramsey show and
it was that until about two years ago
wow a year and a half ago now i guess we
changed it to the ramsey show in honor
of all these ramsey personalities being
my co-hosts
and so but i mean we have god george
i've screwed up more the only thing i
didn't screw up was i just kept coming
to work every day showed up
just showed up and cared and still love
people we all still love people here
it's kind of a core
at the ramsey soul here we we're here to
help you guys we really really are it
sounds like a cheese factory but it's
the truth because the only thing keeps
you going in the middle of all the
corporate bs that you put up with in a
in an industry like the radio business
radio business has got a lot of
wonderful people it can be brutal it's
got a lot of wonderful people but it's
got a lot of sharks too
and uh sharks are snakes and they swim
together and um
and you know they're just corporate and
they they live on fear and they're
worried about next week and they don't
think long term often and then they end
up doing stupid but mean
illegal things and we we've endured all
of that for 30 years it's been a you
know there's a lot of scars a lot of
calluses a lot of process that goes with
this but the great news is
you know when i roll up at um i
stopped to get a thing at the market
this weekend down the country here in
southern middle tennessee guy says hey
you're dave ramsey
man your stuff changed my life when were
you listening 10 years ago you know i
mean wow so i mean that's
you know that that's why that's why
that's why you put up with the sharks
and the snakes to get to help that guy
yeah you were talking about churchill's
story winston churchill and our core
value of never give up and it reminded
me of the winston quote success is going
from one failure to another with no loss
of enthusiasm yeah and that's what
you've done that is what we've done
we're we're we were never the the uh the
prettiest kid on the block we were never
the smartest kid on the block we were
never one of the cool kids
i never have been in anything we've done
and talk radio either that was true and
tv has been true and youtube we're not a
cool youtuber you know
uh there's many people you know we're
not cool enough to be on tick tock thank
god
and um so you know all of that and yet
uh we just kept coming to work every day
and just kept showing up and just kept
answering the call and somebody would
call in and say you know i'm in debt i'm
scared i don't know what to do or um you
know i just got an inheritance of 400
000 i don't know what to do uh you know
whatever it is there's all these life
things and i don't know what to do and
we've been here for 30 years answering
challenges well fpu you know we've
affected 10 million families through fpu
with radio it's hard to tell the impact
and the ripple effect something like
this has
yeah i mean to date we've got 50 million
dollars this year in january through
september in debt-free screams wow so i
mean it's easy to say
on the air
we've had a billion dollars
of debt-free screens
on the air wow that's just the ones that
came on the air we obviously don't have
everybody on the air and a lot of people
don't want to be on the air so that's
pretty crazy a billion dollars
of pissing off banks for 30 years that
never gets old it doesn't get old well
i'm going to call this your 30th
birthday dave just to make you feel good
yeah i mean we could call it the 32nd
anniversary of my 30th there we go
that'll work too
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
i say it all the time if you're a
business owner and you don't know your
numbers you don't know your business and
when markets are shifting it's even more
important you've got to know where you
stand so you make your next move the
right move
and you don't have to be in the dark
here over 31 000 businesses including my
team at ramsey know their numbers
because they use netsuite by oracle the
number one cloud financial system
netsuite gives you visibility and
control of your financials planning
budgeting and inventory so you can
manage risk get reliable forecasts and
improve margins having everything in one
place has saved my team hours each week
since we made the switch to netsuite
netsuite is a game changer so head on
over to netsuite.com ramsey to get a
product tour today that's netsuite.com
ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today we are celebrating 30
years on the air this week with the
ramsey show and one of the things we did
and george this was a lot of fun
all of us sat down all of the ramsey
personalities and did a 30th anniversary
panel
and a uh the video uh that we did of
that is going to drop
once a day or we're dropping several
sections of it all throughout this week
so this out today you can get the first
episode on youtube
watching it throughout the next episode
and it's all behind the scenes stuff and
laughing and us being family and cutting
up and talking about the 30 years and
the things that have gone on
and uh three decades of amazing
different people and the calls or
favorite calls or saddest calls or
funniest calls all that kind of stuff
and so
um again be sure and check it out the
ramsay show on youtube the 30th
anniversary panel drops a video episode
every day this week a new one
so uh you'll be able to check it out all
week long and be able to get pieces of
that and
allow you to just uh plug into that
series if you want to talk about your
life and your money this is the place
the phone number is triple eight eight
two five five two two five chelsea's
with us in dallas texas hi chelsea how
are you
hi dave i'm good how are you doing
better than i deserve what's up
hi um so i was basically wondering so
just as the question is should we
downsize our home
what makes you think you should
uh so i
okay so we were active duty and then we
moved to like a reserve type job with
the military
um so basically kind of lifestyle change
we bought a home it was about 365. we
know about 300 on it but we found out
that it kind of um it's kind of eating
all of our money or a lot of it is
eating a lot of our money um
so so you went you left the military and
as a result took a pay cut
uh no no we just chose to get out of
active beauty and just go into like so
if you didn't take a pay cut why is it a
strain now and it wasn't before
um i think we are just trying to be
smarter with our money i think so it was
a strain before the numbers really
haven't changed just your perspective
yes yes okay
so what's the payment on this thing
so the payment um right now so we owe
about 300. monthly payment is about
how much is it it's like we're paying
about 25
a month 2500 a month and what's your
take-home pay
uh about he makes about 120.
so your take-home pays about 8 000.
i'm sorry 120 000. i know your take-home
pay monthly is about 8 000. oh
i'm sorry about nine to ten nine to ten
okay that puts your house payment at
about twenty five percent of your
take-home pay so where's the rest of
that money we recommend
why is it tight you got a big car
payments
it's not super tight i think we're just
really nervous about inflation we have
zero there's no other debt but we just i
really just want to pay off my house
early i think that's what it is like
i just wanna i'm a little bit nervous
like her inflation we have two kids
and um i think we could just like
be smarter i think we our house is like
2700 supposed to be i don't really feel
like we need it i think we're kind of
living in excess we still heard it
blessed but you're not living in it
no we're not two kids and 2 700 square
feet
in dallas texas is not excess
and making 120 000 a year with 100 with
a 25 100
house payment is not out of line
uh do you need to turn off the news
channel
no is there is it bad feedback or
no i'm asking i'm asking if it's giving
your brain bad feedback it sounds like
that someone has injected anxiety into
your veins
and i'm i'm going to accuse fox or cnn
i don't watch the news really i don't um
i don't where's all this worry coming
from suddenly that wasn't there before
because you said it was a fear of
inflation not the actual effects
yeah not not really like so i think we
just felt a lot like more secure under
under the active duty lifestyle
and it's kind of like oh you're like
sending for not really sending for
yourself but it's like you have to be
smarter like we didn't have a budget
before yeah and we you know we have kids
either and now your husband's around
more
uh yes which i'm very thankful for
seeing a connection here i don't know
i'm thinking that's the problem
do you guys have an emergency fund
we do yeah okay
so here's what i want you to do okay um
the uh john dr john deloney says when
we're looking at stuff like that and we
have that
sense of anxiety coming up we feel our
shoulders tightening up we feel our
throat tightening up you get a sense of
in your body that that the worry has
become too much
um that we need to take up several
series of deep breaths and we need to
look at the actual
facts
not the emotions
what are the actual facts of your
situation and that's what george and i
are easy it's easy for us to do because
we don't live in your world we're just
two guys sitting over here you know
outside the trees and so it's easy for
us to go that's a tree and so um
you know forest in the trees thing right
so you know if you get back from that
there's not anything you've given us in
facts
that worry us and we're the first one to
tell you to sell something if you've
been a goob and overspending we're i
mean we'll tell you sell the car so fast
around here it's unbelievable right
nothing about these numbers screams fire
but what i do think is we may not be
paying attention to what's actually
happening with our money and that's
where a budget can give you that sense
of peace where you have it on paper you
go well this is what we're going to do
we're going to follow the budget then
you're not worried about what could come
your way because you've got a plan for
every single one of those dollars and
you've got plenty of the dollars no
she's but she said they started doing a
budget and it kind of edited their worry
because they're now seeing where it's
going but what you do when you're doing
the budget is you are seeing the effects
of inflation right there in front of you
every month you're seeing oh my dad gum
gas bill doubled you know oh look at
that the food bill went up oh would you
look at that electricity went up 15
because it turns out fossil fuels create
electricity for your emission-free car
dumbbell and so um that's how that
really works so you know i mean it's
like it's not a mission free i just want
to get a little marker and right on the
side of the car
your little car that says emission-free
i'm going to ride on it
first but um anyway yeah so because the
electricity has to get in there somehow
you don't get a bucket of it every week
so um anyway all that stuff shows up and
uh is real and i think if you'll just
look at the numbers set in the numbers
with your husband the two of you always
talking through it and say okay what are
the facts what are my worries
now what of those match up with the
facts and facts are your friends to work
through trauma or crisis or worry or
whatever it is and
um
you know i i i mean all of us that are
ramsey personalities are dramatic people
that's why we're on the air
and so we have a tendency to enter into
drama land if we're not careful yeah and
part of this she said the mortgage is
what's making me feel this way and
deloney talks about this he's going i
want to get rid of this mortgage i don't
feel safe because i owe someone
something now this is a very reasonable
payment but she's looking for the margin
to pay this thing off early she wants to
get aggressive about this and that means
making some sacrifices in the budget we
might need to cut some subscriptions or
a gym membership and things that we
didn't really realize are eating away at
that margin yeah so it everything you
told us chelsea sounds like you're in
really
reasonable shape
yes i'm with you i'd like for you to get
the house paid off but i don't hear
anything here that causes you to sell
your house
as a matter of fact i would tell you not
to sell it right now
not based on the numbers you gave me um
but i would look in the budget and see
what else there is to cut that's um
easier to cut than houses houses is the
most expensive thing you get rid of you
got to move
and that's expensive it's distracting
it's like a root canal it's awful it's
hassling and you've been in the military
your stuff you know i grew up in the
real estate business mom and dad in the
real estate business our furniture was
trained to jump on the truck you know
and you're the same way in the military
everything's on wheels you're used to
moving more than most people but still i
i'm going to tell you this is a good
time for you to just
sit in this moment in dallas texas
and enjoy the moment because you're in a
pretty good place and now let's do work
hard and let's be diligent and frugal
with the money that's in the budget so
we can pay extra on that mortgage and we
can put our 15 away put the money
towards retirement put the money away
towards the kids college and all of that
so
special version of the ramsey show today
celebrating 30 years
george camel on for these two segments
to celebrate that and we will change out
his seat coming out of the next break so
we'll do that george thanks for joining
me on the opening segment for this i'll
be back you know it uh absolutely this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and churchill is here to help
go to their site
churchillmortgage.com ramsey to start
your approval or get more information
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality joins me
on the ramsey show today as we celebrate
30 years on the air in the lobby of
ramsey solutions on the debt free stage
james and rachel are with us hey guys
what's up oh hi where do you all live
temple texas all right welcome to
nashville good to have you all so how
much debt have you paid off we paid off
148 000
in five years way to go and your range
of income during that time from 60 to
140
back down to 100. cool what do y'all do
for a living so
i am currently a manager of a coffee
shop
and he gets to stay home with our kids
yeah
all right i also freelance i do personal
training and i officiate sports on the
side so it's great very cool we switch
roles throughout this process yeah
that'll work good for you guys and the
debt 148 thousand dollars what was that
so we had student loans car payments
best buy home depot target
uh the liquor store no i'm just kidding
and then uh we paid off our house in may
before we finished it
and
you guys so you went from normal to
weird absolutely dramatically yes well
done over five years that's a bit of a
track it was so uh tell us the story how
did you get started on this ramsey way
so we have a two part to this story we
uh i was just a knight and
rachel went to the church for a ladies
night uh what were you doing i can't
remember and i just had a vulnerable
moment i started reading a book and my
wife wanted me to read more so i thought
i was going to be
intimate just start reading and
i actually was reading a sean michael's
book and he was talking about retirement
and then going back to church and then
his realization about tithing and how
man you know that's where do you get
that money from when you're not tithing
and that was where our vulnerable part
was was
we used to be pastors and then we got to
the part with our four boys where money
just went everywhere except where it was
supposed to go and
as she came home i was in tears and
shambles and she just said what's what's
going on what happened and i just said
we're not doing the right thing we're
not tithing
and she ironically that night she said
well i have a solution there's a dave
ramsey thing at the church and we said
what it is and she said it's to get you
out of debt and i said well how much is
it she said it's a hundred bucks and i
said it's a scam
automatically automatically it sounds
like we don't even have a hundred bucks
and then you can't borrow it you know
you got to pay 100 bucks but
i said i'll tell you what i'm a rule
follower so i will do this and i'm going
to show you this this game i'm going to
follow it to the t and she didn't know
that was about to happen and it went
crazy after that
not a scam so how far how far in did you
get before you figured out it wasn't a
scam because that's exactly by the way
what i would have said right i would
have said this guy's a snake oil
salesman the very first we went we
signed up for the course and it was the
very first that very first day and i
said i'm in because it was just a lot of
the things that you said it made sense
and it resonated in my heart and i
thought man i needed somebody to take
over what i wasn't doing right so once
you start hearing uh the teaching yes
then you start realizing okay this is
lined up with scripture it's okay oh
absolutely yes everything was there so
the tithe kind of dropped in your lap
that night and that's kind of what got
your wheels turning rachel how were you
feeling when it came to like just the
money situation overall before you guys
started this process were you at a point
that you were stressed or were you
worried about money like was this a
point that when he said we got to figure
this topic out that you felt relief or
was it the first time you thought oh
gosh maybe we should kind of where were
you in that story i think the tithe was
the biggest part for me because i had
grown up in the church and i grew up
that that was a part of the
understanding of being a good steward of
your money is also tithing to the church
but when we stepped away from being
pastors
we stepped away from a few things that
just
were traditional for me and when he
decided that we needed to be tithing
again it was a huge weight lifted off
for me it just
felt like i was stepping back into
something that i knew was right for us
and as far as our finances go
um
as long as you gave me a grocery budget
i'm fine yeah i just want to be able to
buy food for the the kids yep yeah from
there i didn't he i just let him take
control and we did it together and it
was so much relief yeah i want to say
about rachel that
you know she shared with me man this has
just been a huge weight and i thought
why did you never say anything before i
didn't know this bothered you and she
said because it's god's point to tell
you it's not mine and if i would have
told you you wouldn't have listened and
you needed to hear it from god and i
don't know how long she'd been holding
on to that but it hurt to hear that but
it made me feel good yeah absolutely so
yeah and because when she did bring home
a class it was a scam oh yeah
i'm a six on the enneagram so i have a
hard time with the trust
it's all a scam people are trying to
completely get it
people often say that and they say i
hope i don't offend you it doesn't
offend me because that's exactly what i
would have said yeah this guy he wants a
hundred bucks to show me how to handle
his money that's great yeah i don't
think so and we had a we had a second
part to that so once that first 38 000
we did it in eight months and we were we
were going great and then life happens
four boys braces for everyone cars
more light bulbs back in the house and
and and it took a while well three years
ago um i had two heart attacks
oh wow in a week and unfortunately at
the same time don't cry but we my i was
in the hospital and we lost her dad in
that same week oh my gosh and i just
realized like this was it i remember
hearing a lot of your stories through
your program and just what do you leave
behind where what do you leave yeah you
can leave
all these things but uh it just it
scared me so we buckled down and we took
six months to go back into
getting into that gazelle and we paid
off a hundred thousand dollars in the
last 24 months yeah wow knocked the
house out oh yes what's the house worth
three we bought it for 120 10 years ago
it's worth just over 300 000 now
phenomenal awesome how much you guys got
in retirement savings uh right now
retirement we have fifty two thousand
right right you're approaching a half
million then well yeah i don't know
we're excited about that you're on your
way good stuff congratulations yeah all
right now that you've done it all what
do you tell people the key to getting
out of that is house and everything by
what age
41. i turned 40 in a couple of days all
right happy birthday yes
um i i do we were talking about this on
the way here on the drive and i said i
do think that the
key is really just putting blinders on
it's so easy to look at what other
people are doing especially at the age
we are it's so easy to see that other
people have that other people want that
other people buy and it's very important
to put your blinders on make a
commitment to your family and just move
forward with that right and then in
addition to that james added well of
course all the budget and things but to
me the most important thing is that i
realized through your program this is
not my money and i go back every time
you say how long would it take for you
to fire yourself if you were managing
your family and i was not taking care of
my family and i should have been fired
and so when you realize that it's not
yours even the money the after the tithe
and after the 15 all the money that you
still have is not for you and i believe
in the ministry of availability and if
you don't take care of your stuff you'll
never take care of anybody yeah so i'm
not going to borrow from a credit card
to go help somebody pay for groceries
that's not responsible
and so
yeah yeah way to go you guys we're
excited beautifully done well done thank
you all right bring the kiddos up and
give us their names and ages you want to
introduce them yes so our oldest hold on
we have to tell you real quick why
they're coming up so what they have is
rings we got them included i wanted to
tell this in case people have kids we
did our own little thing
with their ages we didn't know that they
understood the concept of paying off
debt so we made rings and we had it
drooped all over the house you see on
the pictures the chain they cut down
rings each ring represented a certain
amount of money and also as a two-fold
during the house payoff any money that
they invested they paid the house off
they helped and every bit of money until
the house was paid off we returned 50 of
their money back to them wow so when the
house was paid off they they cashed in
tremendously
we had one that was really dialed in
i think we went broke that first month
there was no celebration
running out of time right quick what are
their names this is rhys this is kian
this is liam this is link way to go guys
hey we got a copy of uh baby steps
millionaires total money makeover and a
one-year membership to financial piece
you can enjoy those give them away
congratulations we're very proud of you
all very very well done all right james
and rachel and the guys from temple
texas 148 000 paid off in five years
making 60 to 140 to 100. count it down
let's hear a debt free screen you guys
ready ready three
[Applause]
yeah
those chains are broken i like it
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host for a couple segments here open
phones at aaa 825-5225
so we're celebrating the 30th
anniversary of the ramsey show
so rachel you would have been
how old were we going going there in
1992
four years old
yes four years old yep
was born that year okay there you go i
turned 34 this year but i had told
everyone i was 32. i was 32.
so when i turned 34 i was turning 33 and
i wasn't i missed a whole i literally
missed a whole year just gave it up so
when you ask yeah i have to really think
about it so do you at four years old do
you have any memories what are your
earliest memories memories of this show
uh i remember having to pick you up down
at
opryland which was a it felt like a very
far drive from our house
and there was a little white building
before you got into opera lane and we
had to pick you up there at 4 pm if we
were like going to grandparents houses
or something
on the way
out remember that yeah you would have
been six by then yes so that's the first
time the first two years we were in
downtown nashville so don't remember
that yeah yes and then
when you guys moved to offices
to and you had your and blake was there
but the first in studio
uh yeah in the office i remember that
and you weren't allowed to talk down
that hallway so whenever we worked in
the summer she couldn't talk because it
wasn't soundproof yeah we took an old
closet in the office and turned it into
a studio it was connected to another
closet busted all through and put the
control stuff in there but none of it
was soundproof so people would walk down
the hall of the office and be talking it
would go over the air
and so we put up crime scene tape that
was yellow and put signs up no talking
in this end so rachel's exactly right
there's no talking allowed from one to
four in the afternoon in that end of the
office because our first studio that we
built so we didn't have to drive across
town
at the wtn studios to do the um
do the thing
yeah at least we didn't have to drive
but yeah it was pretty it was pretty
cheap and pretty thrown together but uh
that was our first studio we paid cash
for it paid cash for it yeah
there we go chris is with us chris is in
winston-salem hi chris how can we
help hi how are you great what's up
um so um my husband and i have been
married for 45 years uh we
really um and
did the larry burkett principles when we
first got married and then we followed
you so we're in
good shape financially but this is our
concern my husband uh you know the best
laid plans uh my husband is has a
chronic disease and so he's had to move
to an assisted living
facility um and we were doing okay when
he was in assisted living but now he's
gone to a nursing cause he's had to go
in the same institution he's had to go
to uh full-time nursing care and this is
costing us twelve thousand dollars a
month uh we are still married uh you
know of course and i still have a
mortgage um i mean we're debt-free from
everything except the mortgage and
there's a reason for that but
um my fear is this twelve thousand
dollars a month
uh that i'm afraid there's not gonna be
enough left for me to live on is there a
way for me to without us getting a
divorce is there a way to
sort of protect my income and my um
you know my phone is larger still paying
bills for him how large is your nist
here
oh um
probably a million dollars
okay
all right um
what is the nature of his
uh medical condition what has he got
well he um he's undergone so many
medical treatments he was originally
diagnosed with uh polyneuropathy and
then he's had several
he had a spinal surgery for that from
that he had a stroke and so things have
just kind of gotten worse and worse
and he's only 74. i don't think anything
that he has from what i understand
nothing is going to kill him it's just
that you know he just needs help he just
needs nursing care so and you know this
is not something you ever think that
you're gonna have to deal with you know
so well it's deteriorated you're saying
his health is deteriorating
but there's not a singular diagnosis
that something's going to kill all of us
obviously but there's not a singular
diagnosis here okay
right right so if you go through two
more years of this that's 300k of your
million
yeah if you go through three years it's
450.
and dave i'm okay with paying his bill
i'm afraid that he's if he lives another
20 years i don't
know do you think he is
i'm not wishing him dead i'm just saying
10 i think i think 10 probably you know
okay all right and that scares me i mean
this is a terrible way to be but no no
it's not terrible it's practical i mean
he would want you to do this he probably
does want you y'all can talk about it
you probably do want to do this
so um i mean uh
the other thing is
i'm going shopping
because the average nursing home bill in
america is more like 75 not 150.
so uh and winston-salem shouldn't be
double the national average
um
he's got a really nice place yeah i
think he is he's been there for six
years
he's been there for six years and he
loves it yeah but it was uh it was
assisted living before and it wasn't as
expensive
right exactly yes
so i think if he's going to need full
care you may need to move may need to
move to a different place because if we
if we knock 50 000 bucks off of this
bill
that changes the equation considerably
okay and what's your home worth
uh about 830. and you owe what
200. why
well okay i'll tell you this we had long
discussions about this because my
husband is retired minister and he gets
a housing allowance and this is the one
thing that he says he thinks oh i even
think dave ramsey would agree no dave
ramsey doesn't because you can get a
housing allowance even without a
mortgage
oh okay okay you can you need to go see
a different tax person your tax person
doesn't know how to do housing
allowances
you can take the uh hud median rent plus
any other costs that are involved as a
as a minister
without
when you're getting a housing allowance
without uh taxes
uh without having a house payment you do
not have to have a house payment to have
a housing allowance a tax deductibilizer
oh is that right okay yeah so that's
that's a mythology that runs all through
the ministry i'm so sorry you're facing
this honey y'all worked so hard you've
done such a good job because you're
millionaires yeah you're millionaires
and obviously did you have long-term
care insurance
no because you couldn't get it because
he was diagnosed with this neuropathy
back when you know we were looking at
this absolutely yeah i'm so sorry
yeah i think you need to manage your
costs
for 150 a year i think you could do
in-home care cheaper
hire somebody full time inside the house
that's what's going to ask chris is that
an option
oh i don't know that scares me to death
to think about that i didn't ask you to
do it i said full time
yeah i i i don't know we haven't talked
about that i i would we'd have to look
into it you know
i'm pretty sure you can staff somebody
24 7 cheaper than 150 grand
okay
and um use your house and you know
you know bring in a hospital bed into
the spare bedroom on the first floor
whatever is involved in the ambulatory
issues and so forth i don't know i'm
just throwing out ideas because that's
all i'm here for i'm useless but except
for that but i'm so sorry
but i do think the 144 is not
sustainable and so i think you do need
to change something there just riding
that horse and uh you know off into the
sunset is not a good plan
because if he does live 10 years you've
got a problem yeah
at that rate that's a million four and
how much does law i know they couldn't
get long-term care insurance because of
his specific diagnosis when they were
looking but
in general how much does it cover
for it would cover about three years
of coverage because the average nursing
home stays like 2.8 years yeah most
people don't live
once you go to a fully
a fully assisted nursing home that's why
i was asking not to be cold and not to
wish bad things on the man for certain
our husband of 45 years i don't want him
to
uh
to head off to heaven too soon i'm not
after that that's not my point but we're
trying to do
a math analysis around this and the only
and and one of the pieces of the
equation is date of death i mean i'm
trying to figure out you know how long
has she got to support this
mathematically because two years is not
a problem
five years starts to be a problem yep um
before i head out because i'm done now
on the show today congratulations on 30
years a lot of hard work thank you
helped a lot of people i'm proud of you
thank you proud of you proud of you for
joining in on this it's been a good run
it has this is a 30-year anniversary of
the ramsey show
[Music]
hey it's rachel cruz co-host on the
ramsay show if you want to do your
debt-free scream live on the show visit
ramseysolutions.com
debt free screen we'd love for you to
come to nashville and tell dave your
story that's ramseysolutions.com
debt free screen
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the pods
moving in storage studio it's the ramsey
show where debt is dumb cash is king and
the paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice we help people build wealth do
work that they love and create actual
relationships amazing relationships at
work dr john deloney helps us do that in
particular on his show the doctor john
dolan show is my co-host this half hour
we're interchanging our co-hosts all
throughout the day as we celebrate our
30th year on the air of the ramsey show
30 years we've been rocking this
and uh lots of changes lots of failures
over the years the only thing i told an
earlier group that we have not done uh
we have not quit
but we have failed our way as my john my
friend john maxwell wrote a wonderful
book john called failing forward
and that's that's kind of what we've
done so
my dating life in high school
well that didn't work turned out well
for you though because you end up with
sheila i mean i don't know what your
technique was but you got there just
though
never
give up the winston churchill that's
right i'll never quit
so um yeah if you didn't know folks on
youtube we are dropping in and we did a
30th anniversary panel which was all of
us the ramsey personalities sitting
around talking about the show the
history of the show the fun things the
sad things the all the reasons the show
works all of that kind of stuff and
we've done a series of video episodes
they'll drop one each day including the
first one drops today on youtube so the
30th anniversary panel
check out the video episodes of the
ramsey show
on youtube beginning today and as i said
one each day of this week will drop that
was a lot of fun to do that yeah it was
fun it was cool just uh
just to
hear about the heritage of the show
right and where it all came from and
what the it's cool to hear the purpose
behind it and the
just from the business side
you particularly just you dave could
have walked away with a chunk of money
for you and it the vision for this has
always been about helping since since we
got this thing off the ground and it's
just cool to be able to ride on that bus
now yeah a lot a lot of folks in talk
radio uh 10 15 years ago were selling
out yeah and not selling out in a bad
way i mean they were selling their shows
to the
uh the ihearts of the world or the
westwood ones of the world those kinds
of things and uh dr laura i think was
the first she sold hers for 78 million
and uh she was a little bit larger than
we were in those days and that was
several that was many years ago that's
20 years ago
and um which made you go 78 million
exactly
but then we just go back to okay we
don't really own this we're managing it
for god and we're just here to make sure
that we're uh taking care of his folk
taking care of people out there and uh
so it's turned out eve it's turned out
financially and business-wise also to be
a good move to keep continue to own it
because we make more
on the show and add revenues and other
things than we would have gotten
you know in one year so it's it's worked
out okay because we've continued to grow
the show too
so but uh it's um pretty cool man
interesting interesting ride a lot of
changes in technology we're getting
ready uh all of us just got uh ear molds
made we're gonna go to back to the old
freestanding microphones again and drop
the sports headsets soon i've been in
the sports headsets for a while yeah so
uh you're gonna see another look on that
change i feel like i work at nasa i
didn't know we were doing that james
that's gonna be fantastic yeah um it'll
be interesting i don't know a few months
few weeks whatever get all that
equipment in and get it all tested out
and everything but um
yeah it's uh a lot of radio people have
been making fun of my sports headsets
for years but uh they did well because i
don't get off mic that way when i turn
my head and i'm 80d and distracted so um
but um it keeps the broadcast quality
because it's all audio except for those
of you watching on youtube anyway so
there we go open phones here at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
maria is in norfolk virginia hi maria
welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave thank you for taking my call my
husband thanks you as well you you have
changed our lives in ways that we can't
even imagine
and i'm calling because we're stuck in a
situation and i kind of already know the
answer but
we're not sure how to go about it we
have a relative that has been sending us
silver coins
and we don't think they're worth very
much but she claims that they're going
to be worth a whole lot of money in the
future
we would like to not have them anymore i
guess or maybe we just want to invest in
other ways and she's not understanding
that how would you go about
approaching her
on this scenario because she's taking a
very strong stance on it
who is this his mother his mother
yes it is my mother-in-law
yeah
that was fairly easy
so
talk me out of this because um i've
taken calls on my show about
mother-in-laws who just keep showing up
mother-in-laws who criticize parenting
mother-in-laws who
all all sorts of things that are very
disruptive
sounds like your mother-in-law just
mails a bag of coins
no it actually isn't um she's not very
good financially to begin with um that
was easy to get and
we have quite a bit of problems with
that and my husband and i are the exact
opposite we almost have our business
entirely paid for our homes paid so how
much how much is the value of the coin
she's sending you a year
well when i phoned a coin place that was
local today there may be a 24 worth
they're just silver
so what does it matter
right and that's what we keep saying no
i mean just
throw them in a bucket in the bottom of
the garage and forget it
okay if you throw 24 out the window of
your car on the way to church and that
makes your mother-in-law happy well
that's 24 bucks well spent that's good
it's a great purchase
what is it is it bigger are you worried
about how that she's
slowly um
ruining herself financially and she's
going to be moving in with you guys is
that what this is ultimately about no um
well the thing is is we would be the
only ones that would be financially able
to even care for her
um and would have a home that would suit
her needs come that you know time frame
do you think she's paying two thousand
dollars for 24 worth of coins
i do honestly and so does my husband we
wouldn't be surprised she's very naive
um
and that aspect uh you know she just
lives off social security as far as we
know yeah i i think your husband not you
you don't need to even be in the
conversation you'll be the wicked
step-daughter
in this i already am yeah
we can add layers to that with this
conversation so i think he just said mom
i'm worried about you how much do you
pay for these coins because i checked it
out and they're worth 24
right and just see what she says and
just out of lack the love to her as far
as you all are concerned
i would throw them in a bag in the
bottom seriously in a bucket in the
garage and not worry about it
i wouldn't upset somebody
i wouldn't i wouldn't upset somebody for
24. and i think the the
i think the coins are a proxy
for a bigger conversation which is are
we going gonna let her come live here
and if so what's that gonna cost us
what's what what things kind of like
we're gonna send our kid to college in
five years what do we have to start
doing right now to either lay the
groundwork you're not coming here or to
make it a reality and it's easy to focus
on the coins but it sounds like there's
a much bigger picture of play yeah she's
she's using this as leverage it's a
future it's the uh
this is a symbol of camel's nose under
the tent of a bigger frustration you're
getting ready to get it's getting
a big deal here soon yeah
so yeah it's not 24. if she's paying 25
and you're getting 24 worth i wouldn't
worry about it
but if she's paying 2 000 then that's
just your husband stopping her from
getting ripped off that's right this is
the ramsey show
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality
celebrating today
with us here on the ramsey show 30 years
on the air vanessa is with us in
richmond virginia hi vanessa welcome to
the ramsay show
hi dave i'm such a fan they asked me to
talk quick so i just want to say hi and
thank you for taking my call thank you
how can we help
yes i have a question about roth ira
currently
i have a roth ira that's in a very high
fee
that my husband left me i think about
eight years and i want to be
move it to a index fund
that is low cause low maintenance
and that's what i want to do and i want
to ask you
when should i do that now that the
market is
low or do i wait a couple of years it
doesn't matter and do it whenever it
doesn't um i i want you to be sure what
you're doing you need to sit down maybe
with one of our smartvestor pros and
have them discuss this with you and
teach you about it
because you've been reading something
about fee mutual funds are evil and no
load mutual funds means no fees and
that's not true no load mutual funds
have fees too
including index funds they're annual
maintenance fees and the annual
maintenance fees are higher on those
typically than they are on commissioned
funds
and sometimes so much so that they make
you wish you'd pay the commission
mathematically
so that may not be true with yours
i don't know i own some of each i have
some index funds and i have some mutual
funds uh that are not index funds that
have uh that have a commission charge to
them uh you can set the commission
charges up to be what are called a
shares which is generally what i do up
front you pay your commission or you can
do managed funds which is where the uh
the broker that helps you with this like
a smartvestor pro would charge like one
percent a year and you can have any
mutual fund you want inside of there
then and the fees are the fees are done
away with then other than the
maintenance fees the maintenance fees
are always there on all funds
well it was over a million but now it's
down to 850k
yeah and so
that's not due to fees
huh no it's not due to the fees of
course the market if it was for if it
was a million in january an index fund
would be at 850 right now
oh okay the market's down 15 percent
that every million has turned into 850
this year so far it'll come back
but that's not due to it being a bad fun
necessarily
if it was down to 600 i might be
wondering what the flip is going on
but uh you're sounds like you're
paralleling the market about anyway
um i mean just look up and see what the
s p 500 is down since january 1. you can
google it i i don't know it off the top
of my head but it's right around 15 to
16 something like that
and so and that would put you at 8.50 15
off of millions 150. so um
you know that puts you there i i would
sit down and you know study what it is
that you're
trying to do and make sure you're
actually doing it
meaning are you getting away from the
fees after all that you think you are or
are you gaining stability that you think
you're gaining by going to an index fund
uh because some of these articles on
that are out there make it sound like
index funds fix the whole world and they
don't fix the whole world there's still
index fund s p 500 fund follows the
market exactly it is the market and so
if the market's down 15 you're gonna be
down 15
and if you're in a mutual fund that
outperforms the market a little bit you
might be down 14
which my portfolio is primarily
non-index funds and it's not down as
much as the market is and it's generally
when the market is up it's generally up
more than the market is so it
outperforms the market meaning it beats
the s p
uh and i don't pay a huge bunch of extra
fees that offset that for it you know
what
helped me in a situation like this
because it sounds like this is she's
trying to make this a math problem but
it sounds like she's watched 150 000
evaporate
and when our body gets stressed we've
all heard this fight or flight those are
action-oriented responses i got to go do
something i got to start swinging at
something i got to get out of here
and
the real uh discipline here is just
be still and that's hard because our
bodies are designed to
go do a thing and i got to move it from
here i got to move it to over here and
hear it over here just be still be still
and that's hard to do
yeah sharon and i were hiking in montana
and they've got all these bear signs up
everywhere and you're supposed to carry
bear spray or
something stronger
which is what i would prefer
and all this stuff and so we're walking
up through there and then there's this
long
this like epistle
on a sign of what to do if a bear comes
and i didn't honestly didn't know this
i've been out in woods all my life but
um apparently stand very still yeah
which is really counter-intuitive
if there's a big freaking bear in front
of you
by the way it is a bear market we're
talking about
so standing real still
uh the metaphor works here pretty good
but uh or if you and i are hiking the
old thing yeah who can outrun i don't
have to outrun the bear i just got out
running out run dave that's it that's it
yeah one guy sits down starts putting on
his tennis shoes what are you doing i
don't have to outrun a bear i just you
can outrun that bear you're right i
gotta outrun you that's right but yeah
just be still be still and that's so
hard man it's so hard yeah it's um
just how we're wired but i i think
that's but don't be still out of uh
ignorance uh either
go ahead out of awareness go ahead and
sit down and learn what is the proper
technique
in the middle of this kind of world that
we're in today and the proper technique
in general is just stay invested yeah
but if you're moving from one mutual
fund to another mutual fund they're both
down
that's a net zero
you know deal so you're going from one
that sucks to you know down 15 to
another one that's down 15 you like it
better that's that's a net zero you're
not you're not really losing anything on
that pulling your money out of the
market while it's down it's pretty much
locking in and guaranteeing that you're
going to lose your butt that's right you
lost 150 because it's going to jump back
up maybe next year or maybe shortly
after that i don't know
uh whenever biden gets through screwing
around with this stuff or whoever it is
the dadgum fed or whoever else is
monkeying around with this deal but as
soon as it starts moving again it takes
off again because it always does
then you're going to be standing there
150 000 poorer right so you don't want
to jump out and stay out it's timing the
market will get you killed
uh but in this case yeah i would i would
stick with it so um get some advice
learn about it think about what you're
doing
hey folks have you ever noticed that
when you commit to change one area of
your life it's easier to make progress
in all the others like if you uh said
you're going to be out of debt and build
wealth you lose 50 pounds and you find a
career you love and you start overcoming
stress and anxiety they do all work
together and that's why we put them all
together in subjects in a day-long event
called the smart conference maybe you'll
have a smart plan when you're done
it's going to be in dallas texas on
saturday october 22nd thought leaders in
every space
the top thinkers writers number one
best-selling authors in every area
dr john deloney to my right uh this year
we'll be speaking in the area of mental
wellness all about what are you talking
about this year loneliness loneliness
dealing with loneliness rachel cruz
my daughter will be speaking on money uh
ken coleman be there speaking on career
amy and craig groschel pastors from life
church in oklahoma city will be speaking
on marriage george campbell ramsey
personality will be there speaking
christina ellis will be making her debut
on the stage i'll be there speaking so
we're talking leadership relationships
money uh career everything and all day
long and you're going to learn a lot
it's only 35 because all the vips and
platinums are sold out
you can still get a ticket there's less
than a thousand left they're going
really fast we're scheduled for an early
sellout on this october 22nd dallas
texas and of course
we'd love to have you there so jump in
and get this done our question of the
day comes from blinds i'll go to
ramseysolutions.com
events question of the day comes from
blinds.com they have a 100 satisfaction
guarantee even if you mismeasure you
pick the wrong color they'll remake your
blinds free
uh today's question comes from wendy in
oklahoma wendy writes i use a debit card
for all my day-to-day purchases like
groceries gas restaurants when i
purchase plane tickets amazon items or
anything else online i pay with a credit
card some someone told me you can
dispute a purchase easier with a credit
card than a debit card are you putting
your checking account at risk by using a
debit card for such purchases someone
is a lousy financial advisor don't
listen to p they said i heard that's a
financial planning firm you don't work
with
okay this is normal people debit card
has the exact same protections for fraud
but a credit card does
it does come out of your checking
account and the bank has to put it back
once you dispute it and prove the
dispute that might take a day or two but
i've been carrying a debit card for
years i hadn't had a credit card in 25
years 30 years
and so uh you know pretty easy here i'm
gonna use a debit card this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since
1981. we believe you should have the
freedom to focus on your health while
being supported by a community of
believers giving you the opportunity to
create many more firsts
[Music]
christina ellis ramsey personality steps
into the studio as a co-host we're
alternating all the ramsey personalities
as co-hosts all through the three hours
of the show today to celebrate the 30th
anniversary of the ramsay show it's the
ramsay show's birthday one of the other
things we did to celebrate it was we all
sat down
and uh all the ramsey personalities and
had a great discussion about what we
love about the show uh old times new
times fun times sad times everything and
uh so we have a uh the 30th anniversary
panel we'll call it uh and we're
dropping a youtube episode today on that
and a new one tomorrow and a new one the
next day a new one every day this week
and so a little bit of a series here of
episodes on the history and the behind
the scenes of the ramsay show be sure
and join in that was fun to do wasn't it
that was so fun we had such a blast that
day we're kind of laughing and cutting
up a little too much i wonder if they
edited a bunch of that out i feel like
they probably would somebody was like
are you all going to do the show today
together and i was like oh no not all of
us that would be a that'd be a train
wreck but yeah i mean we're bad enough
when there's just two of us in here it's
very loud very fast yeah lots of
disagreements oh it's a lot of fun on
the dead free stage in the lobby of
ramsey solutions patrick and molly are
with us hey guys how are you
thank you welcome welcome one more time
say it we had your mics down
better than we deserve
good to have you where do you guys live
we're outside of d.c
mary counties yeah welcome to nashville
good to have you down here and down here
to do a debt-free scream of course and
you happen to be here on the 30th
celebration how much debt did you guys
pay off uh four thousand forty thousand
five hundred and thirty four dollars
excellent and how long did this take you
so it took us about 22 months but we
weren't uh
gonzalez test the whole way we were you
know davish every so often
in and out well that's kind of normal i
guess yeah we won't tell anybody but i'm
afraid some other people might do that i
don't know
and uh your range of income during the
22 months um 30 to 34 000. now up to 95
000. yo what do y'all do for a living um
so i work for a government contractor as
like an i.t specialist and i'm a bank
teller awesome okay so the it business
got better or one of you got a job that
didn't have a job or what happened yeah
so i got a job offer we moved
and then she got a good job shortly
after ah cool how old are you two i'm 26
i'm freshly 25. awesome happy birthday
thank you and how long you all been
married uh this year in october will be
two years yeah okay so about the time
you get married you look up and say we
need to go to this get out of debt thing
tell us your story how'd you do how did
you discover the ramsey way
well in 2011 my dad he started he was a
pastor at a church and he decided to do
the financial peace university
and of course they were doing that and
of course i always listened to the show
all the time when i was young and um so
you were like a teenager yeah i i back
in like middle school i guess yeah 14 15
years old yeah okay
so this is definitely familiar for me um
and then you know when we were getting
married um my dad said that we he wanted
us to do the whole program together and
make sure that we're
good financially so um yeah so patrick
you're gonna marry a pastor's daughter
and the pastor says you're going to
financial peace university basically
yeah it was that was you know
conditioned condition yeah yes yeah that
way that way she doesn't end up back in
my basement
something like that right
so what did this journey look like for
y'all what was the hardest part and just
how did you get completely all in on
this i think the hardest part was so
when we first started
we
really
back in november 2020 i was working i
left a full-time job to move over to her
area was working two part-time jobs
she had a full-time job
and um we basically after four months
uh i got told that both my jobs are
cutting hours
and we kind of had to make hard
decisions and you know went to the
landlords like is there anything you
guys could help us out with and
um
started just freaking out because i
didn't know what we were going to do i
kind of feel like i i failed us
and um then out of like the grace of god
on the way of going to of my jobs um
i had a person call for a interview that
i did not even know i applied for
and um
it was over in the area that i'm from
that was three hours away and so i went
i got the job
and um you know
my dad is one of the reasons why we're
out of debt he let us uh stay with him
in his house and you know through that
time we were able to actually pay off
debt and
focus on a lot of other things and it
really is just you know her dad my dad
they're both really great people in our
life
that's incredible very good good stuff
you guys
well done
well done i bet both of them are
cheering you on well uh my my dad
actually passed away in 2019. oh yeah
so what is cheering you on from heaven
absolutely that's that's what i feel
right now i feel his legacy yeah
absolutely yeah he would be nerding out
right now completely
what a way to honor him like the fact
that you're here the fact that you were
listening back to 2011 with him that's
just that's incredible that's one of the
things that really propelled me is the
fact that you know he asked me that was
one thing that he really wanted to make
sure that we stayed on and i felt like
that's what i needed to do and just
started to just really focus in on that
that's that's powerful yeah patrick
you're a man of honor you're a good man
it's good stuff well done very well done
you two very proud of you good moves how
does it feel to be free
amazing yeah it's crazy we haven't been
on family vacations since our honeymoon
so this is like our first time out and
even then it was during covid so yeah
exactly
so this is a lovely horrible
honeymoon
they make you stay inside everything
what a horrible honeymoon
you guys are fun way to go very very
cool you all are young and you were
newlyweds when you started this journey
did you guys have some people around you
who thought you were kind of crazy yeah
definitely we had um so my family's not
familiar to this at all
my family has already been through the
whole program and everything so but they
were like yeah yeah so it was my family
was a little skeptical like they were
just like i don't know um
you know really should you really be
doing that especially when it came to
the student loan stuff and we just
really um so we finished paying that off
back in august right the sat the sunday
right before biden did his whole thing
and you know everyone's like oh are you
guys gonna like request the way back and
i feel like i told her and she agreed
with me is that
we got out of this ourself we didn't
need anyone else anyone else's help
nothing just us doing in the hard
putting in the hard work to make sure we
got out of it we're so proud of you yeah
that's amazing i think i said it a while
ago you're a man of honor that's pretty
impressive yeah you this the value
system that you two are carrying is
going to take you a long long way very
well done
very very well done good stuff good
stuff all right what advice do you have
to somebody needs to pay off forty one
thousand dollars and they're making
thirty grand
say stay gazelle intense yeah that's
what i have to say it's just you know
you might think there's nothing else you
can do but there's always something else
you can do live like no one else yep
yeah so that later now you can live and
give like no one else you're gonna be so
wealthy it's gonna be unbelievable
wow
hey we got a copy of the baby steps
millionaires book for you and speaking
of that that's the next chapter in your
story to become baby steps millionaires
and a financial peace university
one-year membership maybe a
nay-saying family member needs to go and
you can give it to them i don't know
same with the total money makeover book
will give you maybe you can give it away
too so good stuff you guys you need
you're a neat couple very very very well
done all right patrick and molly heroes
from the washington dc area 41 000
paid off in 22 months making 30 to 34.
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream three two
[Applause]
one ah
i love it way to go youtube
way to go
very cool well dave congratulations on
30 years of those stories they are good
stories doesn't get old doesn't get old
doesn't feel like 30 years when you hear
that every day
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
christina ellis ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
america celebrating this week the 30th
anniversary of the ramsey show
originally started out called the money
game
then we converted it to the dave ramsey
show and then when it wasn't just dave
ramsey we had all the ramsey
personalities starting to be co-hosts
with us
uh about 18 months ago i guess it is now
we changed it to the ramsey show hardly
anyone noticed when we did that but
that's okay it's a good thing no
complaints anyway because we've got all
these uh
bright and beautiful people to help us
as co-hosts now so here we go chad is
with us in denver colorado hi chad how
are you
hey great thanks for all you guys do and
happy birthday well thanks what's up
so i was just accepted to a specialty
residency program in my field
and i just am interested in hearing your
thoughts on the best way to make that
happen financially it's across the
country in your neck of the woods
and it's a two-year program and so our
biggest question is
we would love to be
moved back to this area if possible if i
find a job here afterwards so the big
question is do we
rent the house out for those two years
or go ahead and sell it and
to help get through
what's the specialty
uh endodontics i'm a dentist so to be
specializing in root canals okay all
right and you're saying we
hate you and your wife
yeah we have three boys uh i'm good at
working on teeth i'm not a financial
guru
okay
um and the the is the specialty uh
the fellowship paid for
so the total cost for the program for me
it's not paid for is eighty thousand
dollars that's not including uh living
um i currently make
i gross about 300 000 as a k-1 employee
and
have
about sixty thousand dollars in the bank
um sixty
five thousand dollars in iras
and then the other thing is so you're
gonna pay cash for this you got a way to
do it
uh i would love to do that yeah yeah
well you can i mean you just got to
concentrate
um
now what's the house worth
uh eight hundred thousand what do you
owe on it
uh four hundred and ten thousand
and do you have any other debt
i have thirty thousand dollars in
student loans still okay and and no
other consumer debt other than that okay
um
other than raising your kids
and being a good husband
job one is get this specialty
degree completed
nothing should distract you from those
three main jobs husband father finish
the degree no distractions and this is a
uh an academically strenuous field of
study is it not
yeah i'm probably looking at 80 hours a
week yeah you mean you got to not only
be pretty smart you got to work ethic
yeah yeah you don't need renters in
denver
why are you trying to do this talk about
a distraction
sell the house
okay
you wouldn't live in that house
after you get this specialty
after you get the specialty your
income's not going to be 300 anymore
right
even if you move back to denver you're
even if you did denver and you might not
right but even if you did denver you're
not gonna live in that house
you're gonna be making a lot more money
you're gonna get a better house than
that
uh yeah
my wife and i are pretty simple we kind
of like our house we'd love to be here
but um
i mean things do change right yeah they
do
i i would sell that house and i would
rent and i would keep my life extremely
simple and i would concentrate on being
a husband a dad and graduating
okay debt-free i appreciate you
you know emphasizing those priorities
yeah just the simplicity of life
we forget when we put all these things
on our plate that they all
even if they're adding
income or financial benefit to our life
they take other things from our life
yeah like the more crap i own the more
repairmen i have to know
you know
like when i was at the lake house this
weekend i got to put the boats up for
the winter i got to get the furniture
moved up and i told the guy helping me
move all the furniture i'm like all this
fun is hard work
you know i mean it's just your life is
more complicated the more the more
complicated it is the more strenuous it
is the more anxiety there is the more
stress there is and you need to be when
you're in a strenuous field of study for
a very intense two-year period of time
singularly focused that's what i would
do if it was me i would not want the
that's a luxury for you to be able to do
that i'd sell the crud out of this house
i mean it's just a stupid house well and
i think with the profit that you'll make
from the house with the income you're
going to have while it feels hard to let
go of this house now you like dave said
you're going to be able to get something
beautiful once you've graduated you'll
have peace in the meantime and a
beautiful home once you graduate pay off
your student loan pay cash for your
finish
come out make a big old pile of money
dude just go kill it just go pile it up
just stack cash man right you're already
killed you can live anywhere you want to
live and here's the thing
if you don't have a house in denver then
you will more you will more evenly
evaluate all of your opportunities in
other locations if you had the house in
denver you'd be kind of like i'll take
that one i'm not quite as happy with
that offer but i'll go over there
because the house is there and they say
you have this magnetic pull back to this
it's a house
right again i grew up in real estate
business there's a house on every corner
they're everywhere well even while
you're in the program i just think
you'll have so much more peace and
freedom on your vacation
to go where you want to go if you've got
that house in denver you're probably
going to want to go back and check on it
versus maybe you all go to the beach
maybe you do something else that's fun i
think it's just gonna it's gonna free
you up a lot in the meantime
see i wasn't thinking about the beach
i'm always thinking about the beach dave
there is that with you christina there's
that yvette is up next your vets in
boston hey yvette what's up
hi there happy anniversary thank you to
the show
sure um i've been listening for about
eight months and
um i really have learned a lot of little
tips i kind of like your last kind of
like your last caller i've i've been
kind of involved in a lot of grants and
moving around you know for this program
that program
and i feel like i'm really late in the
game um how old are you i'm 51.
i don't know how you're getting around
you decrepit old thing
i appreciate that it makes me feel
better actually
um
i you know i i could be it could be
worse but i'm embarrassed that um so for
retirement at the moment i have i mean i
am proud of this i have a little bit
over a hundred thousand could be much
better
um
at the moment i'm single i don't have
kids i'm finally sort of where i want to
live i hope permanently what's your
income and
uh it's pretty decent it's about 95 000.
good what's your name um
you'll get no debt at all okay i've
never owned a house never owned a condo
i'd like to now yeah good and you've
been listening to us for eight months
you've heard us talk about the baby
steps right
yep
okay yeah that would tell us you need to
be saving towards the down payment on a
house
and when you get the house purchased on
a 15-year fixed where the payment's no
more than a fourth of your take-home pay
you got a down payment already
i do i have a little bit over a hundred
thousand for that good um
and i kind of feel like
i want to i'm so earnest i talk about
you all the time to my friends they're
really annoyed uh like but i want so
badly um to
put more than 15 in for retirement to
try to catch up no just put a hundred
thousand down on the house put 15
percent aside and everything above 15
start throwing it at the house as soon
as the house is paid off then you can up
it you've got plenty of time
you're gonna have millions of dollars if
you follow those baby steps exactly
millions with an iss
all right that makes me feel good
and i love your humble spirit i love
that you're coming in you know feeling
you know a little behind having
questions but at the same time don't
have shame about where you are you're
doing great and you still have plenty of
time yeah you've got you've got a lot of
decades i mean what you can pull off
into the average millionaire following
our stuff pays off their house in 10.2
years which means some of them do it in
seven which is what you're going to do
and um
then that gives you the rest of the time
to put however much you want above 15 in
the retirement but if you save 15 of 100
000 that's 15 000 bucks a year and you
never get a raise
for the entire 20 years
and you pay off your house during that
time your net worth is going to be about
3 million bucks
that's if you're doing that in good
mutual funds without a match
you're going to be just fine you got
lots of time but just lean into those
steps and don't let up don't let up
don't slip back into stupid or something
and you'll be just fine good stuff
christina good half hour thanks for
having me happy 30th happy 30th to you
life is good
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the pods
moving and storage studio it's the
ramsey show where debt is dumb cash is
king and the paid off home mortgage has
taken the place of the bmw as the status
symbol of choice we help people build
wealth do work they love and create
actual amazing relationships
open phones this hour kent coleman
ramsey personality host of the ken
coleman show best-selling author of the
book from paycheck to purpose is my
co-host today special week here on the
ramsey show we've had all the ramsey
personalities on with us today
at different points being co-hosts
because we're celebrating
30 years the 30-year anniversary of this
show starting thank you guys some of you
have been with us the whole time out
there
and both of you we're thankful for
it's a little bit bigger than that but
this is a special milestone you know we
were talking about it during the break
you know very few people
in our world do anything for 30 years
you know
people don't stay in jobs for 30 years
anymore
sadly we don't see as many 30-year
marriages as we used to see you know 30
years i mean three decades that's uh
that's quite a quite a journey and
what's so great about it is is it's just
full of the same formula
the same mission
just helping people get control of their
money to be able to change their life
and uh it's fun as we see new people new
generations coming in and consuming the
show differently uh to see how the
show's evolved yeah and from talk radio
to podcast to youtube to all the
different venues and the various people
carrying podcasts now all over the place
you know the fine folks at amazon music
are carrying us now spotify of course
apple um google play all of them you
know it's everywhere now and um we
appreciate all of you that listen to it
however you uh consume the show we
appreciate you being there uh we all sat
down all the ramsey personalities and
did the 30th anniversary panel
where we all sat and uh actually cut up
yeah we had a couple times told stories
it was a little bit i'm glad there was
someone there to kind of direct the
traffic because you get that bunch of
people in the room it's like train
trying to nail jello to a tree that's
true but uh we got through it and uh
filmed a an episode or a series of
episodes that'll be posting on youtube
the first one posted today we'll post
one every day this week on the 30th
anniversary panel talking about the show
and uh the things we love about doing it
the things we love about you guys out
there uh and celebrating all of you of
course and so uh check out the ramsey
show uh video episodes again popping on
youtube today and every day this week a
new version dropping and uh be sure you
check those out uh pretty special
production that the team put together
yeah a lot of fun and uh
we get to share so much about what the
show has uh meant to us as we've seen
so much transformation the role the
small role we get to play in it uh some
great experiences some great laughs a
lot of tears it's a wonderful wonderful
conversation a lot of fun it's a show
that actually brings hope in a world
where the most shows just bring anger
and uh so there's plenty to be angry
about no doubt but um we're gonna choose
to wag more and bark less
and that's what we're here for so here
to help you out open phones at triple
eight eight two five five
two two five ken coleman ramsey
personality is my co-host this hour or
this half hour mary is in seattle hi
mary how are you
hi i'm great how are you better than i
deserve what's up
so
my question is this
my husband passed away in january of
this year oh my god and i think i
have
thank you
um i have two young children um who i
now and
i will be having to support them you
know
and i
have been a stay-at-home mom for
essentially my entire adult life so i
have no
real job experience to put on my resume
and facing employment
you know with child care costs a minimum
wage job just isn't going to cut it so
i'm trying to put together a plan to
establish myself in a career where i can
take care of myself and my kids how old
are you
i'm 25.
how old are the babies
they're three and two
how old was he
he was 36. my goodness what happened
uh suicide oh i'm so sorry i'm so sorry
oh my goodness oh wow yeah it was
obviously unexpected yeah yeah sure
um was there any life insurance involved
um there was a 50 000 policy in my
daughter's name that's in a trust until
she turns 18.
who put that in the trust
uh the the life insurance he had left it
he that was the only insurance he had
through his work and it was in her name
so the insurance automatically put it
into that trust because she's a minor
they did say that i'm able to go to
court and become the
custodian of it but i'm not sure if i
should do that or you should i should
just leave it and i think you're getting
scammed by the life insurance company
okay um the money was left to your
daughter it was not left into a trust
and them sticking it into a trust
arbitrarily is
way over the top
okay there was no will so it's not their
job they they overstepped their bounds
but anyway yeah i'm going to deal with
that later but in the meantime we got to
get you working because you got to feed
two babies girl
yes i'm scared with you and we'll help
you do you have any support any family
around you in the immediate area
um i i you know i'm in washington right
now i'm
actually in a couple days moving back
down to california to be closer to them
okay um so i'll be close to the
emotional you know and
presence support of my family i'm not
expecting financial support from them no
but will they be able to support you in
watching the babies during the day what
we're trying to figure out is what are
our real costs going to be and i'm glad
you're moving close to family we're
going to need that for a job by the way
uh i'll explain in a second but will we
be able to help with child care
i will be about two hours away from them
so it's a little bit better than 20
hours but
as far as day-to-day child care i'm
going to have to pay someone
or figure out some something yeah
well um
there's a lot going on here um
what we what we want to start with is
just what you're good at doing and i
know you've not had a long work career
but the fact that it remains you have
talent and whether that's people talent
or process type talent that means
details and organizational things or
maybe it's in a creative nature what
you've got to focus on right now is
for the long term what am i talented at
and with some additional training i can
be quite skilled
if we're going to have to make more than
minimum wage which you're going to be
able to so long term we want to look at
talent and skill and what you're going
to love to do short term if you can make
twenty dollars an hour at target uh
which you can uh or working uh you know
for any big box retailer that's paying
really well like that if we just got to
get some income in quickly we're looking
for something in the 20 to 25 an hour
range there's a lot of remote work right
now
you're just looking for something that
you know you can do it's not a function
of you have to have all this training
it's i can do this work but i want to
help you give you a head start
two things i'm going to give you a book
from paycheck to purpose when i give you
the get clear assessment which is going
to give you some real direction and then
i'd love if you'd be willing to to
schedule you to call me on my show or i
can spend some more time with you and
come up with some very specific ideas in
that area hey you hold on austin i'll
help you with that ramsay's going to
walk with you honey yeah we're also
going to put you through financial peace
university so you can learn how to
handle money and keep it under control
while you're doing this we'll help you
with the career and the money yeah
that's what we're here for you hold on
also pick up we're going to give every
bit of it to you as our gift hold on
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host open phones at
825-5225
javier is with us in cleveland ohio hey
javier how are you
i'm doing well thanks for taking my call
guys sure man what's up
so my question is uh i'm in baby step
two
and
i have about 15 000 in consumer debt
um
now i know baby step two is paying off
all your debt except for the house so my
question is should i sell the house to
pay off the debt or should i keep the
house and continue paying it off as i
have been
i would keep it unless there's some
reason to sell it
do you like it
yeah i love the house the only problem
is the house is about 20 miles from my
current job so i will need to buy a car
i think there's about 20 000 in equity
in the house where'd your car go
well i was living in colorado the last
two years so i didn't really need a car
but now i'm back in ohio so i definitely
need a car
well i mean how long have you been in a
house that you own 20 miles from work
without a car
uh so i just came home i've owned the
house for three years i had tenants in
there previously so now that i'm living
back in the house i'm i'm gonna need a
way to work so i see i can save for a
car i'm staying with my relative at the
moment closer to my job gotcha okay what
do you make
i met about 3 thousand a month okay
and how much debt do you have not
counting the house
i have about fifteen thousand
okay and do you have any money at all
i have my emergency fund and i have
about
another 700 saved up for a vehicle
the emergency fund you mean baby step
one one thousand dollars or three to six
months
just baby step one okay all right so you
have seventeen hundred dollars to your
name you make three thousand dollars a
month
and um
and the house is worth what
i believe it's worth about 120 and i owe
83 on it
okay
all right
how much you say you own oh i mean you
haven't got a car yet
correct what's the other day y'all ready
so the 13 000 is a
credit card consolidation and i owe
another 2 000 on an old title loan
okay so if you had um
if you sold the house you'd probably net
uh it sounded like 20 000 bucks or so
right let's just call it that for the
discussion purposes if you had 20 000
cash in the middle of your kitchen table
right now and you did not own a house
would you go buy that house with it
i would probably buy that house with it
but
i don't think it'd be a bad idea to take
13 of it
pay down that credit card consolidation
and take the rest to buy a vehicle
i just think it's better that i got into
the house at four percent
versus buying a house today at six
percent
yeah but also
when you're broke doesn't matter
right and right now i mean we're sitting
here discussing you buying a 700 car
right
how old are you
26.
so if you sell the house and you use
that to jumpstart your life and solidify
your life and you launch into a career
and you launch into a reasonable car and
you're a hundred percent debt free and
you get on a tight budget and you use
all of that to build your emergency fund
of three to six months of expenses and
then you save a down payment to buy a
house two years from now
that will be a successful ending
if you sell the house and you screw
around for the next two years and sort
of do this stuff
um you're going to end up wishing you'd
kept the house
right
but if you want to lean in and do the
financial piece university stuff
hardcore
selling the house will catapult you into
wealth more than keeping it well
you see how i'm doing that
yes sir but i mean you got to use every
ounce of the money coming out of this
thing to cause your life to be excellent
and a solid foundation and we're living
on a tight budget we're not spending
everything we make we're going to
accelerate this career get the income up
ken
uh beyond where it is yeah and uh you
know let's double your income in the
next four years yeah this is not about
making things better in the temporary
this is about changing the course of
your life and if it becomes the catalyst
for that absolutely agree i think it's
the right move you have to commit to the
whole plan 100 the whole process and go
okay i'm gonna take classes get
certifications i'm gonna change jobs
again
i'm gonna get the parts of my life that
aren't stable stabilized i'm gonna get
plugged into a good church i'm gonna get
my life straightened up i'm gonna do
everything right i'm gonna be clean as a
whistle i'm going to be uh working this
budget tight i'm watching what i'm doing
i'm going to be losing weight i'm going
to do everything man i'm going to get
this whole thing going and if you use
this house money to do all of those
things you will end up a millionaire
because of selling the house
because you're not driving a freaking
700 car for the next nine months making
three thousand dollars driving 20 miles
for the opportunity to make no money
yeah and be careful with who you
surround yourself if you sell this house
be careful who you surround yourself
with a lot of broke people giving bad
advice
and telling you to live it up a little
bit
this is about discipline and diligence
walk our baby step plan out and then
diligently
stay with it don't get too tempted to
buy a house after you sell this house if
you got a rent for a while just walk
this thing out and then you're going to
be in really great shape you'll be ahead
of most people your age yeah yeah hang
on we're going to put you through
financial peace university as our guest
to help you do all of that javier hold
on all right mike's in daytona beach
mike what's up
hey thank you for taking my call sure
how can we help situation
yeah my situation is as follows i had
lost my job back in covid
a year later everything started to go
very well and
now i have a salary making more than
i've ever made
however things went to collections
during that time period
so now i'm curious do i
pay off what's in collections i'm not
being bothered by any of the collectors
the only debt i have currently is a ban
and i owe about 13 on the van
and then i have my
rent and internet and what have you
yeah so how much do you how much is in
collections
uh
probably
[Music]
25 grand
okay from what
uh consolidation loan and credit cards
okay
and you you legitimately owe the money
you just weren't able to pay it at the
time
correct yeah i can you know look at my
credit report in the past i saw they
were there but i'm not being hounded
yeah i've seen they've been charged off
and sold to third parties already yeah
being hounded isn't the issue you
morally owe the money sir you took money
from someone you need to give it back to
them
correct yeah um but do i focus on those
first and just do snowball effect on the
smallest largest no i'd knock out the
car if they're not hounding you i'd run
two debt snowballs let's run the first
one on active debts
clear the car any other debts you have
that are active you're paying payments
on clear all of them and then i would
work at that snowball on the old dead
debts smallest to largest
now how long has it been since you paid
on these
on the
debt collections yes sir
oh
probably
three months i i went online and i saw
okay i owed money to another phone call
and i negotiated
got you you settled but i just
yeah i mean i negotiated and said hey i
can pay you this much now and we settled
on the payment
um for the collectors but there's
there's still more that i owe you know i
was doing a snowball effect but then
okay so you've settled some of them but
there's still some outstanding
correct okay when you settle them make
sure you get it in writing that they're
accepting x amount
whatever the amount of greed on as
settlement in full get that in writing
email or otherwise
yes sir i already have that and print it
out good good and hard copy print it out
so you don't lose the email later
because it will come back to get you but
yeah you need to go through and settle
the rest of them after you get the car
paid off that's what we're going to do
what are you making now
household income
is monthly after taxes is 13k
oh good lord you're going to blow
through this in no time of course of
course you're going to yeah
you've got to give me a day we are 3k
but i have lost my job yeah okay the
great news is you got a great new job
and you're gonna clean up your mess fast
good
yeah yes sir yeah go do it dude
absolutely there's no no upside to not
paying what you owe a it's an integrity
issue b it's a legal issue c it's a
credit issue
uh d
did i mention it's an integrity issue
and the right thing to do i think i
mentioned that yeah go do that one yeah
and you know it's just gonna come back i
mean these things it's like a splinter
it eventually will fester and cause you
a problem it's just a matter of whether
it's five months or five years
and so you want this stuff out of your
life you want your you want when you
look in the rearview mirror you don't
want to see headlights you want to see
blue lights
they're coming around and around and
around this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
if you haven't heard we're changing out
the ramsey personalities every few
segments today george campbell ramsey
personality in for the last two segments
of this hour today doing that because we
wanted you to hear from all of them
we're celebrating this week the 30th
anniversary of the ramsay show and be
sure and join us on youtube for the 30th
anniversary panel which is all the
ramsey personalities including me all
sitting around talking about
the show talking about you the callers
you the listeners and we appreciate you
be sure and check it out on youtube the
first episode dropped today there'll be
a new one dropping every day for this
week as we uh take that rather lengthy
interview that we did and spread it out
over a few days well over 30 years i
mean we're lucky to just get one hour of
tape in that panel well there's a lot to
talk about a lot that's it exactly in
the lobby of ramsey solutions elijah and
caitlin are on the debt free stage hey
guys how are you keep doing good
better than i deserve where do you all
live
um nashville tennessee oh you're right
here neighbors yes sir awesome and all
the way from down the road to do your
debt-free scream how much did you pay
off
one hundred and twelve thousand five
hundred and thirty two dollars way to go
and your how long did this take 36
months good for you and your range of
income during that time from 65 000 to
180.
wow nice jump in three years dude
three years you triple your income
that's awesome
very cool what do y'all do for a living
so we were
he originally worked with hospitality
and i was with an attorney but then
during covet hit and we started our own
cleaning business your own printing
cleaning
business yes sir so both of you all in
now on the business yes sir and it is
working it is working working your tail
off and cashing the checks
way to go guys proud of you very cool
crushing it good stuff all right what
kind of debt was the 113 000 we had 37
000 in student loans around 20 000 and
what credit cards and then the rest was
medical and car oh wow okay how long you
two been married four years okay so a
year of marriage you kind of go along
normal and then three years ago
one year into your marriage you take off
on this how did all this happen how did
you get started on this rams on the
ramsey way
um i guess in 2019 well our parents have
always talked about you and and my
father i and i took economics with greg
carson no way yes i love him yeah you
know coach carson started the curriculum
he was the first person to teach it in
high schools and now it's been taught in
tens of thousands of high schools 48 of
high schools have taught it in north
america and greg carson is a lot of the
reason the way he teaches man he's into
it he is amazing i went up and spoke to
their class the other day up at father
ryan oh wow okay that's awesome so yeah
we started there but we didn't really
follow like we should my mom was always
had the envelopes out you know had the
of the debt snowball going on and i was
like you know i was a little kid i
didn't really know
2019 hit and like we said covet hit and
we were terrified because he got laid
off from his job in hospitality and
hotels sure everything shut down
everything and then my attorney who i
worked for was like we're cutting hours
there's just nothing we can do sorry so
i was cleaning we love to clean he loves
to clean
or ocd
so i was like you know what let's take
that and run with it and
we did it got so busy when i opened the
business that i had to pull him out i
was like please come help me he went to
work at kroger because he got laid off
and he's just not a man to sit at home
so
we did that and i pulled him in and i
was overwhelmed and i was like please
come work for me please help me i you
know and it took off from there yeah
please come help me or work please come
work for me that might have been harder
yeah i had to convert i had to convert
the business license to the husband and
wife
it was so awesome so you all doing
residential or commercial commercial and
residential okay what's the bulk of it
um mainly residential we're mainly in
westhaven yeah okay yeah
that's brilliant everyone's living in
their own filth during cover they're
like staring at their dirty house yes
they're like i will happily pay for
someone to clean this up yeah it was
wild i thought we weren't gonna have any
business because of covid but like you
said everybody wanted to be clean and
not everybody was as freaked out as
everybody wanted everybody to believe
right exactly y'all aren't scared of
work that's for sure sir good for you
guys impressive yeah you're just i mean
you took control man that's a powerful
stuff
so what made you decide at that 36 month
mark to go was it all the layoffs you
got oh crap yeah we got really scared
and we really we don't ever want to be
in that situation we don't ever want to
know where you know our meal is going to
come from how we're going to get our
kids
you know fed and taken care of or like
no never again we were getting things in
the mail like oh hey you don't have to
pay your mortgage this month you can
just you know they were doing that whole
weight thing and we're like absolutely
not you know we cannot do this but um
after that he got on board and we both
got on board it was me um was the more
the spender he's looking at me like tell
them you're the spender but
what was the hardest thing to stop
spending money on
that really just crushed you going out
to eat
going out to eat and doing stuff you
know as a family we had to do a lot of
stuff inside free stuff
wow
it was hard that's a tough one but it
was worth it it was so worth it well
worth it so you pay off a hundred and
thirteen thousand in 36 months what do
you tell people the key to getting out
of debt is
stay focused stay disciplined because
all of our friends all our family i mean
we had family members that were like
we're not doing the dave ramsey we're
not going to eat crackers and bologna
and i'm like he's not it's not he's not
saying that it was we got a lot of no
it's beans and rice
crackers and baloney
so much flavor
but yeah so that
i mean that's kind of yeah you live like
no one else later you get to live like
no one else so now now that you're dead
free what are they saying
they're asking us how we did it so yeah
we're letting them know yeah yes yes
not to mention you guys have worked an
amazing amount of hours i mean you've
worked your tail ends seven days a week
for the last
two three years yeah are you going to be
able to hire some folks and slow down
just a little bit now
we're trying speaking of that mr blake
thompson he works here we clean for him
we have for two years and he
gave us the book um you had he got it
signed for us at christmas and we were
over the moon you signed it and it was
uh entre leadership oh good
and it was like the next step for our
business is like wow okay we're here we
got this debt free now let's work on
building this so
wow what a coincidence
in the original producer
to get in he was in here he was so
excited we were excited he was there to
give it to us and it was i don't know
just like he must have not known you
were here today he would have been out
here
so yeah that's full circle on the 30th
anniversary it's amazing think about
blake the original producer and you guys
running well and greg carson teaching in
her high school you know the whole thing
you know that's just if you keep at it
long enough you'll eventually get
through to you
took me a while but yeah excellent job
you guys are incredible i'm so proud of
you proud of your business exploding and
your courage and how you went out there
and prove the american dream is alive
and well it is so
if the hotel lays you off and the
attorney lays you off all they did was
cause americans to be uh
no i don't know free enterprise system
let's go start something and make more
than we were making anyway from you
people yes exactly here we go game on
prove it out i love it i love it it's
powerful powerful that's a good thing
it's amazing the number of highly
successful businesses that were started
by someone who was a wee bit desperate
and had been put down by someone else or
cast aside by someone else so to speak
so very very cool
good stuff good stuff how does it feel
now that you're free
amazing so good a weight off of our
shoulders yeah we can breathe we got
more books for you baby steps
millionaires because that's the next
chapter in your story for sure uh
financial peace university one year
membership and a total money makeover
book maybe that's how you can answer the
question from somebody that's asking you
give them a copy of that book that's
books helped about 8 million people and
uh you brought your daughter with yeah
bring us to bring her up let's introduce
her to her how her name and age please
this is eliana and she is 11. oh
beautiful
all right
very cool well done you two proud of you
your heroes thanks excellent excellent
job elijah and caitlin and eliana from
nashville 113 000 paid off in 36 months
making 65 to 180. count it down let's
hear a dead free scream three three two
one we're debt-free
well done you two
[Applause]
small business started a family tree
change there's a lot to love about this
story they're impressive impressive
family a lot of good things happening
there beautifully done you guys
beautifully done
this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day first
corinthians 9 24
do you not know that in a race all
runners run but only one gets the prize
run in such a way as to get the prize
winston churchill said never give in
never give in never never never and
nothing greater small larger petty never
give in except to convictions of honor
and good sense never yield to force
never yield to the apparently
overwhelming might of the enemy never
quit never quit
never quit
which is our secret around here george
for 30 years we failed a lot but we just
never quit
lots of people smarter than us lots of
people richer than us lots of people
that have big companies behind them uh
opening doors for their shows and doing
other things lots of people owned by
other companies we were
freestanding show meaning that we own it
we syndicate this show we have to get
the radio stations in each city to take
the show
we have to negotiate with a podcast
company to carry the podcasts uh we have
to do it all we have to pay for all of
it
we reap the benefits from all of it but
uh
we have done a lot of stupid stuff but
the only thing we did that uh continued
to work was we just never quit keep
showing up for 30 for 30 years we are
standing on the shoulders of giants like
you and many of the leaders that came
before me dave so thank you so much for
providing hope for so long to so many
thank you it's been a good ride george
it's been a really really good run a lot
of fun the ramsey gold planner is up for
sale on pre-sale uh we'll be coming out
very soon and shipping them to you uh
get you ready for 2023 uh there's a
devotional each day a full calendar each
day a layout on everything stuff written
by rachel cruz dr john deloney george
camel
me
uh other ramsey personalities all the
way through the thing the ramsey gold
planner is a must-have for your 2023
planning
it is always a big seller it always
sells out meaning we don't buy too many
of them but it's available on pre-sale
right now and you can check it out at
ramseysolutions.com for those of you
that are into the planner christy wright
ramsey personality years ago started
this
and uh as she has moved on to other
things we have converted the idea to
just the ramsey gold planner and it is
uh completely redone new cover new
everything beautiful beautiful piece for
next year and we want you to get it
pre-ordered and get it done
andrew is in boise idaho hi andrew
welcome to the ramsay show
hey guys thanks for having me how you
all doing better than we deserve what's
up thanks
um my eight-year-old son uh accumulated
about 120 in cash and he's been asking
if he should have it in the checking
account or keep it in cash and
throw in envelopes or should we put a
portion of it in savings just kind of
want to get your thoughts on that
very cool good for him good for him
where'd he get that
uh birthday and we got the ramsay chore
chart and he's accumulated quite a bit
from that also cool cool so you're
working the financial piece junior
system with the three envelopes the give
save and spend envelope
yes sir yeah i would keep it divided
into those and when the save envelope
gets big enough you can go down and open
a savings account
that's what i would do for an
eight-year-old a checking account
assumes he's going to be using a debit
card or writing checks and doing
transactions from that account i really
don't want him doing transactions at
eight years old if he's gonna do
transactions that's at the toy store and
he's gonna take a little cash down and
buy something or the sporting goods
store or whatever and buy something
but he can just take cash out of his
spend envelope for that that'll be just
fine we're not gonna be using the
checking account actively now i do move
kids into a checking account in their
teenage years so that we can teach them
how to reconcile the account we used to
call it balancing a checking account
it is a good idea even though hardly
anyone does it anymore to learn to
actually write a check
to fill it out
uh admittedly i've not filled one out in
a very long time the checks that are
written here at ramsey are all automated
including my personal account uh and
most people use electronic bill pay and
those kinds of things george do you
write
i just wrote a check today dave did you
how many dummy checks do you write a
month uh probably
less than one i'd say in a year i
probably do four or five okay and
usually it's to save money so i can
avoid transaction fees oh yeah you know
i'm frugal but it's a great scale but i
usually have the cash in my pocket so
i'm still an old cash guy but i want to
teach kids to do transaction the method
of having a savings or checking account
in their teens andrew is just to be able
as a dad as a mom to put your arm around
them and teach them how to do these
transactions it's not to set them free
and act like they're adults they're not
old enough to even drive yet or buy beer
so we're not gonna turn them loose with
two thousand dollars in an account but
uh i actually put my kids clothing money
into their checking accounts when they
were fixed 15 16 17 living at home and
let them make their own clothing
purchases
and uh that that taught them you know
the difference in
banana republic and old navy you know i
mean it teaches you the the difference
in the budget here that chirp costs what
and suddenly when it's coming out of
your account even though it was my money
that went into your account it wakes you
up right and so it really taught them
budgeting and then when they went off to
college they already knew how to operate
a budget and they already knew how to
live on a set amount and they already
knew how to operate their checking
account and so we set them up we're
training them to be good adults is what
we're doing it's not actually just to
give a teenager freedom i don't need to
give a teenager freedom i want to teach
them
i want to teach them yes that's the goal
and then with that comes some freedom
with that comes some liberties but this
is not to just like oh we now have given
you a piece of plastic and a cell phone
and so that's how that's a rite of
passage into adulthood in america today
oh and your own facebook account this is
dumber than a rock right here yeah once
they start earning money and actually
getting some paychecks then it's time to
go okay we can do the checking account
get a debit card yeah yeah and you know
if you're gonna turn over like uh you
know our kids were making lots of money
doing odd jobs for other people
babysitting mowing grass whatever that
kind of stuff that can all go in there
but it's not um
i want to teach you parents this this is
so and this is so countercultural and it
sounds mean but it's
um
your your children are
children
by definition legally until they're 18.
and so
i can't tell him what to do with his
money when he's 16
is the sign that you are a wuss
not a parent
okay you can tell him what to do it is
he doesn't have any money until he's 18.
she doesn't have any money i don't care
if they earned it or not it's
technically not their money they live in
your household it's technically your
money legally speaking
now i'm not suggesting you take their
money and go buy cocaine for you with it
that's not what i'm talking about okay
but i am saying this idea that somehow
that they you don't have rights as a
parent to teach your 16 year old how to
handle money he or she earned
doing something out there in the
marketplace it's absolute bs you are
shirking your duties as a mom and dad it
is your job
to put your arm around them and kick
their little butt and teach them how to
handle this stuff you got to tell them
to take a shower and you got to tell
them to brush their teeth so they don't
have free reign here yes kids the
inmates don't run the freaking asylum
and so you know they but parents are
turning them loose with thousands of
dollars
cell phones and then wonder how they get
tied up in sex trafficking you know
wonder how they get sucked into stuff
because they don't have the emotional or
mental maturity to deal with some of the
issues that we stick them into they are
still children
by definition more is caught than taught
yeah and so you gotta model this stuff
too if you're if your kids see you doing
stupid butt mistakes with money and
swiping that credit card that's what
they're going to learn is normal and
okay yeah so you just turn them loose in
the wild you know you that's not your
job you didn't toss them the car keys
and they never had a driving lesson
they'd be suicidal i thought that's what
they did in the south
just let them go at 14. put them out in
the field where there's no trees and
other people but yeah drive your truck
across there whatever but i mean but
still it's no you don't do that you got
to give driving lessons you give money
lessons you give work lessons
you give
technology lessons so that you're not
going to live with your nose stuck in a
screen
and so you're going to have you have
some balance here this is a tool it is
not an obsession and so on and we just
walk kids through this stuff but my
friend andy andrews says our job as
parents is to
not to raise great kids but to raise
kids that become great adults
and that is a different goal that's
wisdom and that changes everything and
so that's your job moms and dads so
andrew you're a great dad thank you for
teaching financial peace junior if you
don't know folks that's a t box of
teaching aids to teach kids 12 and under
how to handle their money and learn i
learned to do chores get paid for them
like a capitalist
not a socialist
and um you don't make money just because
you breathe you work make money when you
work that's how this works in the real
world boys and girls that eight-year-old
has a higher net worth than most adult
americans think about that
that's sad
bucks in the bank
all right george good job today good job
james andrew zach ben and austin in the
booth congratulations on the booth dudes
and everybody else on 30 years
of this show this is
the ramsey show we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the friends of peace christ
jesus
do you love a good dave rand want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
you